what's going on everybody Johnny Mason a
place I'm here with CEO and founder of
value tainment Patrick bet David we're
sitting having some fun times in Costa
Rica phenomenal time just had a great
team dinner with the entire company here
and I wanted to sit with Patrick for a
little bit before actually going to
smoke a cigar some guys on fire scope
some of the guys I want to ask Patrick a
entrepreneur based question and you know
Patrick you know I'm in Jax a lot people
from other country came in but still in
America a lot of people are still taught
to go to school get the degree and we're
almost somewhat promised to get this
corporate job that's going to pay us
what we're worth and we're coming to
find out that we're not earning what
we're worth and we kind of get stuck in
this 60 70 $80,000 income after working
7 8 9 10 years for a company and a lot
of people somehow lose the younger
factor what would you say is the cause
of losing the hunger factor and why we
get stuck in that sometimes you know
it's a it's a phenomenal question that a
lot of people ask and a lot of people
try to answer and so what is it so a
simple thing one we were having a debate
earlier today with me and a friend of
mine Kandi's girlfriend and I were
having a conversation about LeBron James
and Jordan and she said LeBron James is
the greatest of all time I had a Michael
Jordan so you got to be kidding me
Michael won you know six out of six and
championships and you know never went to
Game seven and she says but LeBron James
is this and this and that I said look
let's do an NBA draft pick okay you pick
your top five I picked my top five I
give you first-round draft pick pick the
player at the peak she picks LeBron FERS
I pick up MJ she picks what does she
take second she takes magic second I'm
like she takes LeBron and magic on the
same team and I take Shaq second I said
it's game over I said have the most
dominant center of all time and I have
the most competitive fears you know just
a beast of an athlete at as Michael
Jordan you have LeBron and magic similar
positions and then she starts telling me
all these things about LeBron so but
there's a part of that you don't know of
LeBron on the argument I make that I'll
give you
she says what is it I said first of all
Michael Jordan grew up in a family where
both his mom and dad were extremely
driven up pushing this guy to compete
and Michael Jordan had something LeBron
did and now Michael Jordan had an older
brother that was better than him in
basketball
so his older brother kept bullying him
for the longest time I have two boys my
oldest son bullies the younger one and
it benefits the younger one I know it
sounds like what bullying is about you
know benefits the younger one so he's
constantly being bullied by the older
one and MJ had that LeBron never had
that the Bronco up in an area was you
know his father was and their mother had
issues you know he had to be raised by
you know certain people in a church and
a pastor took him down and helped him be
a man but he never had a Dean Smith he
never had a coach so the first thing
reason why most people don't leave a 60
$70,000 your job is because no one
believes in that no one believes in that
they don't have somebody that believes
that they can go out there and do
something bigger and make a million two
million dollar your income matter of
fact when somebody even says that to
them they're offended by it because they
think it's a joke they think this person
is trying to play mind games with them
if you've never had anybody that's
believed in you looked looked at you in
your eyes for at least 20 30 40 times 50
times and told you I believe in you
because the first time anything they're
full of it second time they're full of
it third time they're folded for time
you like it fifth time you like you but
you don't believe it sixth time you
don't like you
seventh time you like you you don't
believe in the 10 15 20 then you believe
in a little bit then you believe in a
little bit more than you believe then
all of a sudden you fully believe in it
then from there it's history and you're
not doing something big for yourself so
number one is believe nobody believes in
them to environment surroundings you're
not in a surrounding a where where your
best comes out you're not in a
surrounding where people are pushing you
challenging you it's not a competitive
environment that brings out the best in
you
third a lot of times people's dream
machine gets burned out they no longer
dream anymore because after being
rejected so many times and maybe having
a father or a mother or an ex husband or
boyfriend or girlfriend or somebody keep
telling you that your average and
ordinary you eventually end up believing
it and if you eventually end up
believing it guess what happens you
don't really point to all these other
things that you can do it and then
lastly is you just
believe the wrong lies and I'll tell you
what the wrong lies are regardless we
all believe lies I'll tell you what lies
I'm talking about you either believe
you're a loser which is a lie or you
either believe you're gonna be a
millionaire one day which is a lie right
here's what I mean by that
here's what I mean by that if you
believe you're a loser that's a 100% lie
unfortunately 90% of world thinks
they're losers deep down inside that in
securities they've been humiliated
before they've had painful losses
they've had devastating losses they've
had terrible breakups they've had you
know tried one business didn't work they
lost their car in a house and a wife and
whatever and so that made them believe
there's no way they can do so they're
losers well the other part is somebody
believes hey I think I can't be a
million in one day that's also a lie how
do you know you gonna be a millionaire
you don't know what the hell you're
talking about
but if you're gonna buy a lie why not
buy the lie that you got to be a
millionaire one thing it means alive
well if I'm gonna buy a lie I'm gonna
buy that second lie because we have
choices which lies we're gonna believe
it unfortunately here's the crazy thing
most people end up making the life of
you're a loser the truth that make sense
most people end up making the lie that
I'm a loser and that becoming the truth
cuz they end up becoming losers because
they bought that lie and a few who buy
the lie that one day I can become a
millionaire end up becoming a
millionaire because they bought the lie
of becoming a million and eventually
becomes a truth I'm a 1.8 GPA kid from a
broken family I never once finished the
book in my life till 21 years old I was
forced to read Of Mice of men and that
was then this is now never finished a
book cover to cover how to teach English
teacher her name was Miss Collins and
she would make fun of my reading
abilities because I didn't read that
well and then I was told by a guy named
Robby Solomon who was my boss at Bally's
and another man named Cisco who the
first two sales managers that actually
believed to me being decent in sales and
he kept encouraging me that I could want
to be good salesmen and Robby recommend
me how to win friends a master daughter
of Sela my sister recommend me how to
win friends and influence people another
person I recommend
me Rich Dad Poor Dad the rest was
history I never thought I was going to
be you know almost gave up sales and
went back to being a Hummer mechanic for
a Hummer dealership the only Hummer
dealership in town which was in
Camarillo I was going to go be a Hummer
mechanic because that's what I did in
the army
I was going to go become a cop had
thrown in the towel for everything so
what happened all of a sudden somebody
believed I was hungry I believe the lie
that one day I can be a millionaire I
started reading I worked my butt off I
put myself in humiliating situations I
got embarrassed rejected you know
ridicule violently impose all this stuff
and then eventually you know nowadays
when people see my videos and he talked
about value taming and they think I came
from this middle-eastern family when my
dad was a lawyer my mom was a doctor and
I you know all this other men we live in
Beverly is that's not the case I'm just
a regular guy that worked on was
following area so a long-winded answer
to your question I would say all of
those things combined together is why
the sixty seventy thousand dollar guy in
corporate ends up staying there for 30
40 years and never really ends up
fulfilling their potential living their
dreams but they get stuck there but good
news is every single one of them can get
out every one of them love love a little
of it Patrick thank you for that and you
can follow Patrick on Patrick bet
david.com as well as value team and go
to youtube and follow the value taemin
channel subscribe to the channel also
you can follow us on John Mason
money.com as well as the John me some
money YouTube channel and we'll see you
guys back home in the States take
everybody say bye bye